they said nothing come on I got this
family in five days only to everyone we
lost to take a stand with you vengers we
got finished this this is the fight of
our lives every journey has an end
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
every takes I missed that giddy optimism
adventures and game rated pg-13
everywhere Friday how's it going
everybody it's Warren and as I mentioned
in the video I did about an hour ago we
are getting so many new TV spots for
Avengers endgame and this time this TV
spot comes directly from Marvel they
uploaded it on to their YouTube channel
and it wasn't a promotion on Instagram
and although this new TV spot only has a
couple of new scenes it does debunk a
major theory that has been going around
so I'll talk about it and break it all
down in this video but a reminder I'm
doing a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a glow-in-the-dark painting of Thanos by
Globe I bow and if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain I'll talk more
about the giveaway at the end so this TV
spot starts off with Natasha talking she
says I used to have nothing and then I
got this family she could obviously be
talking about The Avengers of course
they're her family but in this
particular scene I think she's talking
about Hawkeye and his family because as
we learn from the very first Avengers
film Hawkeye was supposed to kill
Natasha
but he didn't instead he turned her into
an agent for shield so when she says I
used to have nothing she's talking about
her past life as an assassin and then
when she talks about her family I
believe she is talking about Hawkeye and
his family because as we have all
speculated Hawkeye's family most likely
got dusted which is why he takes on the
Ronan persona and we know how close
Natasha was to his family we saw that in
Avengers age of Ultron and if you look
at the scene in this new TV spot her
hair has red in it with a little bit of
blonde which means that enough time has
passed to wear her red hair is coming
back so she has most likely already gone
to Japan and found Hawkeye or has at
least heard that his family was victims
of the snap and I think in this scene
she's talking about Hawkeye's family
taking her in and the next big thing
about this TV spot isn't a new scene but
new dialogue we hear for the very first
time
Thor say whatever it takes we've heard
Captain say it we've heard Tony say it
we've heard Natasha say it we have not
heard Thor say it now many people
believe the theory that we have never
heard Banner say it or we never heard
Thor say it because they're actually
going to die in Avengers in game now I'm
not saying that they won't die in a
in game but the theory that the reason
we don't hear them say whatever it takes
is because they're going to die that is
now disproven because we have now heard
Thor say whatever it takes so the
reasoning for that theory goes right out
the window
and if I had the guess we will most
likely hear the Hulk say whatever it
takes in a TV spot before Avengers and
game comes out and then at the end we
have another scene with Tony and Steve
just joking around with each other being
buddies again finally reunited and Tony
says to Steve I've missed that giddy
optimism so it's nice to see that Tony
and Steve are finally going to mend
their friendship and that does it for
this new TV spot let me know what you
think about it in the comments down
below
and if you haven't seen it yet I've done
an Avengers in game a rap parody just
for fun if you haven't seen it I'll link
it up above so you can check it out and
again I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet
and a glow-in-the-dark famous painting
by globe by boat you can also find some
of his other work at glow by boat comm
I'll put the link in the description
down below all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is to be subscribed to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your